today marks the start of the next
chapter in this country's fight against
covet 19.
a few hours ago the prime minister
announced
thanks to the progress that we've all
made
we will be lifting the plan b measures
and returning to our original plan a
this is a moment that we can all be
proud of
the culmination of a brilliant national
mission
that helped us to withstand the omicron
wave and restore more freedom to this
country
it's a reminder of what this country can
accomplish
when we all work together
we'll shortly be hearing from the chief
medical advisor to the uk health
security agency dr susan hopkins
but before we do i wanted to talk about
how we got to this important milestone
and what this means for our fight
against this virus
let's start with how we got here
back in july
we made the decision
to take step four of our roadmap
so that we could roll back the
restrictions and move closer to normal
life
this wasn't an easy decision
but taking this step when we did
backed by the warmer weather and the
school holidays
it helped us to enjoy the greatest
possible freedoms for a number of months
as i said when i announced that change
this showed us how we can learn to live
with covid
but i also warned
that a more harmful new variant would
have the potential to set us back
four months later
our scientists
learning from their colleagues in south
africa
were amongst the first in the world to
help identify a new variant omicron
a variant that was capable of spreading
faster than any coveted variant that had
come before it
spurred by this new transmissible
variant
case numbers rose to record levels
and incredibly
over a third of the uk's total number of
confirmed covert 19 cases
happened over the last eight weeks
there was a lot we didn't know about
omicron
but we did know
that we were in a stronger position than
the previous winter
thanks to that decision
to open up in the summer
and to the solid defenses that we've
built up over time
so we decided not to return to the
lockdown measures
as many countries in europe have
because i've always been extremely
conscious of the impact that blanket
restrictions can have
for instance on jobs
on education
on mental health
instead
we pursued a different path
one that allowed us to take a balanced
and proportionate approach
we put in place the plan b contingency
measures that were set out in the autumn
and winter plan
these measures
left us with far fewer restrictions
than most in europe
and they brought us valuable time
time that we could use to assess the
omicron variant and reinforce
this country's pharmaceutical defenses
since we announced plan b
15 million people
have stepped forward to get their
boosters
we've smashed records again and again
including a record
1.06 million uk vaccinations in a single
day
we've also massively expanded our
capacity for testing
and we expect to have some 400 million
lateral flow tests available this month
alone that's quadruple our pre-omicron
plans
on top of this
we secured even more antivirals and
treatments
and deploy them directly
to those people with the highest risk
thanks to this huge collective effort
we're more boosted
than any large country in europe
we've created the largest testing
program of any country in europe
and we've procured more anti-virals than
any country in europe
that's why we are the most open country
in europe and today we've announced
plans to go even further
our plan was to use the time that plan b
gave us
to give ourselves extra power
in our fight against omicron
this plan has worked
and the data shows
that omicron is in retreat
today's ons data shows a four in
infections
including in older age groups
hospitalizations have also fallen over
the past week and the number of patients
covered patients in intensive care beds
is now at the same level as it was
back in july
i've always said that we would open up
the country as soon as the data supports
it
and earlier today that's why we
announced three important changes as
part of our return to plan a
first
starting immediately
the government is ending the guidance on
working from home
and i know that many people have already
started talking to their employers about
making arrangements
to return safely to work
second
from the start of next thursday
mandatory certification based on
vaccines and tests will end
but of course organizations can still
choose to use the nhs coveted paths
voluntarily
third
also starting next thursday will no
longer legally mandate the wearing of
face masks
but we must suggest
that there are worn in enclosed and
crowded places especially where you come
into contact with people that you don't
normally meet
these changes will take effect sooner
even sooner in classrooms where we will
no longer require face coverings from
tomorrow
and the department of education will
shortly remove the guidance on their use
in communal areas
as well as these changes
we're also exploring what else we can
ease where else we can ease restrictions
we're looking to replace legal
requirements on self-isolation with
guidance and advice
and in the coming days i'll be setting
out our plans to further ease
restrictions on visits to care homes
the steps that we've announced today
represent a major milestone
but it's not the end of the road
and we shouldn't see this as the finish
line
because
we cannot eradicate this virus
and its future variants
instead
we must learn to live with covid in the
same way that we've learned to live with
flu
and will be setting out our long-term
plan for living with coed 19 this spring
we must stay vigilant
and be mindful
that there could be bumps in the road
ahead
although we've worked hard to make sure
that the nhs will be ready and resilient
building nightingale surge hubs
and signing new deals with the
independent sector
it is still facing significant pressure
this winter
even before the omicron wave we had a
coveted backlog of elective care
and now unfortunately that covered
backlog will be larger still so we must
proceed with caution
a pandemic
is a marathon not a sprint
even on this day of progress
i urge everyone
to think about what they can do
to help keep the virus at bay
whether it's washing your hands
letting in fresh air
or getting tested and self-isolating if
you're positive
but the best step
that we can all take
is to get vaccinated
it was the jabs that have got us this
far
and the jabs can keep us here too
i'm so grateful
to all the staff the volunteers the
military everyone that worked on the
rollout program
we asked you
to come forward
and you did in your millions and it's
because of you
that we've been able to take these steps
today
but for as long as there are people
who haven't been protected
we know that our defenses aren't as
strong as they should be
and the nhs will be under more pressure
than it should be
so please
if you haven't had
your first second
or third jab
it's time to come forward
help us keep this success story going
and protect the incredible progress
that we have all made